what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and with the new
daredevil born again series announced
for disney plus coming in the spring of
2024 i know that fans are really really
excited to finally have charlie cox
playing matt murdock again back in the
mcu for longer than a quick cameo and
spider-man no way home but at the same
time i also know that some fans are kind
of worried that marvel studios is kind
of going to water down daredevil a
little bit the netflix daredevil series
is amazing and it's brutal and it's very
dark and this i think is where the
concern mostly stems from that disney is
going to take that darkness and
brutality and water it down to where in
the mcu we have a daredevil that's not
that dark and not that brutal well today
we have some bad news about that but i
also think we have some good news about
that at the same time and we will be
covering the daredevil series and
everything concerning daredevil leading
up to the series so if you want to stay
up to date with daredevil and the rest
of the mcu be sure to subscribe now we
all know that daredevil is going to be
appearing in she-hulk not only have we
seen him in some of the trailers but
they announced this at san diego
comic-con so it's no secret however we
have recently found out what kind of
daredevil we can expect to see in
she-hulk and it looks like we are going
to be seeing a different side a lighter
side of matt murdock slash daredevil in
the she-hulk series and i know this may
bum some people out but stick with me in
this video and i'll explain why this
isn't such a bad thing but first let's
talk about what was recently revealed
this report and news is coming from
thedirect.com in an exclusive interview
with jessica gao the creator and head
writer of the show and in this interview
she talks about how we are going to see
a lighter side of daredevil but also a
lighter side of all the cameos that are
going to be coming in she-hulk and it
looks like there are indeed going to be
quite a few cameos and fingers still
crust that the thing from the fantastic
four could show up although at this
point it seems like a long shot but hey
you never know but here is what she had
to say about the lighter side of
daredevil and actually using daredevil
in she-hulk she starts off by saying
well first of all we were shocked that
we were able to use him like when we
first heard that he was on the table i
mean we couldn't believe it we kept
thinking like okay at some point
someone's gonna say just kidding like
it's a cruel joke and you can't actually
have him and it just kept going and kept
going now obviously it wasn't a joke
daredevil is in the show we've seen him
in the trailers and that would be a
really really cruel joke to play but she
continues on and says and charlie is so
wonderful he's so gamed to do whatever
and he's such a wonderful actor and a
wonderful human being what was so fun
about bringing him and daredevil into
our world is that people have already
seen a daredevil who was very dramatic a
little bit on the heavy side very dark
brooding and yes that is the daredevil
that we know that is the daredevil that
i think a lot of people actually really
want to see but here's where things get
a little bit different she continues on
and she says and it was so fun to be
able to do and we do this with every
character cameo from the mcu is we take
them from the environment that you know
them from which is a much more dramatic
and action-oriented role much more on
the serious side and we bring them into
our world and they get to play in the
tone of she-hulk and they got to explore
and we get to see a lighter side of that
character so don't freak out just yet
about seeing a lighter side of daredevil
there are a few things to note about
what she said that are very very
important one is that she confirmed that
there are going to be a lot of cameos
she said it was fun to be able to do and
they do this with every character cameo
from the mcu so cameos are coming now
we've already seen some we've seen emil
blonsky back as abomination we've seen
wang i even think there could be a shang
chi connection here after all similio
did tease that he is showing up in other
projects before his next shongxi project
of course we have daredevil and again
fingers crossed ford the fantastic four
or possibly even a mutant heck if we're
lucky we'll get a doctor doom reference
or a doctor doom cameo but not holding
my breath for that main point she hulk
is going to bring in a lot of cameos but
of course what everybody is concerned
about is that jessica gau said that we
are going to see a lighter side of the
character that is daredevil a lot of
people don't want this but she specifies
that they get to play into the tone of
she-hulk i have seen a lot of people
freaking out online stating that they
don't want a lighter daredevil but you
have to keep in mind daredevil is going
to be in she-hulk so daredevil has to
match the tone of she-hulk and she-hulk
is a comedy she-hulk often times in the
comics breaks the fourth wall much like
deadpool and i'm pretty sure she's gonna
do that in the show as well and this
show has the potential to be very very
great but back to daredevil keep in mind
this is just him debuting in she-hulk so
of course they're going to match the
tone of she-hulk this does not mean that
daredevil the character and the show
itself is going to be lighter and think
about it at this point in time in the
mcu we have had plenty of instances
where we get dark and brooding
characters where we've had violence and
horror and things that basically fit
with the tone of daredevil we've had
john walker basically decapitate
somebody with the shield of captain
america doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness showed us some pretty brutal
scenes especially with the illuminati
and don't forget deadpool is going to be
rated r and blade is coming to the mcu
as well and blade is a pretty dark
character and plus not to mention the
thunderbolts movie is coming as well and
these are essentially super villains
coming together to do dirty jobs i doubt
that's going to be a light-hearted movie
sure some of these movies may crack
jokes but the action and the characters
are going to be probably pretty dark and
brutal so despite hearing that
daredevil's mcu debut outside of
spider-man no way home but his debut as
actual daredevil not matt murdock but
daredevil despite hearing that the
daredevil debut is going to be lighter
than normal don't think that that means
that marvel studios is changing the
character to a much more lighter version
that's not what that means they are
simply putting daredevil into she-hulk
and they're going to match the tone of
the show which is going to be a
light-hearted comedy with some action in
it and this is actually a good thing
think of it like this we are going to be
getting a daredevil and spider-man team
up kevin feige actually confirmed this
at san diego comic-con he said that
spider-man and daredevil are both going
to be a part of the street team and as
you start to see you talk about ghost
rider we've got blade we've got doctor
stranger at the supernatural right
angles we've got the street level with
our announcement of daredevil and of
course spidey going into the street
level uh heroes and cosmic so one can
imagine that when daredevil is teamed up
with spider-man in the mcu the character
is also going to be a little bit more
light-hearted not the dark and brooding
one who bashes blood out of people all
the time that we're used to they're not
gonna have that version of daredevil
with spider-man but in his own show they
can and i'm assuming they will and it's
18 episodes long and of course we have
d'onofrio back as kingpin so the same
chemistry is going to be there between
charlie cox and dinofrio so for those
who are worried about this statement
that daredevil is going to be a much
lighter version in she-hulk do not worry
i do not believe that that is going to
be permanent in any way at all they are
simply adjusting to fit the tone of the
show much like they will do with the
spider-man team up as well but once the
daredevil series comes i'm assuming that
that dark and brooding tone is going to
come back and of course i trust in kevin
feige after all they are dedicating 18
episodes which is two times as much as
we've seen so far or i should say about
to see with she-hulk they are clearly
giving him the attention and time that
he deserves so i'm not worried about it
but hey let me know your thoughts about
this in the comments down below and
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof